yo is wild 9041 the bootleg cabs show I
told y'all I had a special guest calling
in I wasn't lying we got my dog on the
phone right now Big Sean what's up
player what's up player what's up doc me
talk to you man - cuz you my dog even
holding me now for years man what a few
people who was on it early I'm just
respecting it and showing real love man
so I appreciate you I'm glad
everything's going well for you give me
are you down there in Tampa trying that
man that's what it is hey I saw today
Wiz and amber it's official that they're
getting divorced you just went through a
public break up you and Wiz are super
close no they've nothing yeah man it's
all over TMZ she filed for divorce um so
I mean is there any advice you would
give to your big homie Wiz I know you
guys toured together and you guys have
been making music together for a very
long time they filed for divorce today
yeah me man I know man like it bro such
really good people it sucks you know
what I'm saying cuz I'm really you know
closer with and it just is unfortunate
but you've been through like you know a
public breakup that people kind of kind
of saw from the public side is there any
advice you would give to Wiz
yeah I'm saying summed up where's is
like one of my best friends like he
comes to my house frequently I mean
probably like last week maybe two weeks
ago he was at my crazy just came while
running out knock on the door
I'm in my room on the balcony he like
comes through is just talking to me
about like life I'm not saying I knew
what was coming or what wasn't coming
but the fact that that happened is this
really crazy man you know my advice and
I'm not gonna blast anybody else's
business right that's my dog and he
knows I love him so is it so that's for
real that's real my brother right there
[Music]